Speaker 1: Let's talk about the political
football. That is the debt and deficit. We've
talked about this piecemeal over the last several
weeks because there have been continued examples
of Republicans talking about how can we afford all
this stuff that Joe Biden wants to do when there
was no question under Trump about how do we afford
anything? And the guy exploded the deficit by
significantly higher, higher margins than we've
seen in a very long time for any president.
It's a political football in the sense that
Republicans claim to have as a guiding principle,
fiscal conservatism. Part of that is balanced
budgets, meaning you spend less than you take in.
They also want to change tax law to take in less.
And it's really just sort of a package of trying
to restrict government from really doing things.
That's really what's at issue with Republicans.
Anything they can say to justify government
not doing something, not helping people,
not being involved in something they will they
will do it. But then as soon as they want to spend
money, the concern is about fiscal conservatism
go away. This gets us to two days ago on the Neil
Cavuto program on Fox News, where James Lankford,
James Lankford is not just a Republican senator.
He's not just a radical
extremist Republican senator.
Something about the guy is really creepy.
And many of you have written to me about
the same thing. And Neil Cavuto, good for him.
Every once in a while, Neil Cavuto does this.
Neil Cavuto calls out James Lankford and says,
Where were your new concerns about Joe Biden
spending when it was Donald Trump doing that
spending? All right. So let's take a look at
it. We're going to go piece by piece here now.
Speaker 3: You might call it socialism, Senator.
Democrats say Republicans are fine ones to start
lecturing on spending of any sort since debt also
piled up and the Trump administration
packages on paid for piled up in his
administration. That was even before the pandemic.
Speaker 1: So Lankford starts shaking his head
and, you know, he's got something good coming.
Speaker 3: Republicans have sort of like a leg to
stand on. Yeah, of course we do. They're going
back to the 2017 Tax Cutting Jobs Act saying
you cut taxes and you should never cut taxes.
You need to raise taxes like we're planning to do
as they're playing this giant tax increase. If you
look at whatever the tax cuts and Jobs Act from
twenty seventeen, we had a rapid expansion
of the number of people getting employed,
the number of people actually paying taxes.
Speaker 1: OK, so, so, so two things. Their
rapid expansion of the number of people employed
job creation was positive in that early area
of the Trump first Trump's only term. So there
were jobs created at the start of Trump's term
at a slower rate than at the end of Barack
Obama's second term. That's number one. So
while there was job creation, it was slower under
Trump than Obama. But number two, the job creation
did not accelerate when Trump's tax plan was
passed. So Republicans like to just point
and say we passed the tax cut plan, the tax plan,
whatever you want to call it, and jobs continued
to be created. The truth is the job creation did
not accelerate. And if you are of the mindset that
it was the tax plan of Trump that created jobs,
why did job creation slow down after that was
passed? The second piece is more people employed
than ever. This is the labor participation
sort of talking point that they love to
do. Remember that the United States is a
country whose population keeps growing. So at many
times we have a record number of people working.
And a record number of people not working,
it's a very deceptive technique that they
will use to their I don't use it because it's
deceptive. OK, let's continue. Here we go.
Speaker 3: So an increase in tax revenue happening
starting in twenty, nineteen, twenty twenty. We're
the fastest growing economy. We've had 50 years
since piled up. Right. And so did the debt. I'm
not faulting you for that. So I'm just saying that
whatever, you know, whether you boost the economy
and that was clear. Did it help the economy? My
point is that the debt piles up and lecturing
on either part parties. You know, Neil
Speaker 1: Cavuto is keeping his eye on
the ball and he's saying, you're talking about
jobs and you're talking about revenue. Aside from
the fact that you're lying about those things,
the deficit went up and that can't be denied.
Speaker 3: What is too much money?
We're beyond that right now.
Well, I get it. Getting back to balance is
something that needs to be in the conversation.
Speaker 1: But OK, so anyway, Neil Cavuto pointing
it out and you're not going to get an answer from
James Lankford. This this is a really common
one. And, you know, the problem I have with
this entire debt deficit thing is there's a
real conversation to be had. And unfortunately,
we can't really have it with these people because
they're just operating in fantasyland. The truth
about debt and deficit is complicated. A country's
national debt is not analogous to a household
where, hey, you know, if the income is five grand
a month and expenditures are six grand a month,
you're falling behind a thousand dollars every
month. You're either going to start having to
charge and take out loans to pay that on which you
pay interest and you fall further behind. That's
how a household thinks countries are different.
And then the so so first of all, in terms of
what it means to have national debt, relative
to what does it mean to have household debt,
not analogous. Republicans love to to simplify
along those lines. But more importantly,
if a country's economy is continuing to
grow, even in evaluating the level of debt,
we need to be looking as debt as a percentage
of GDP. If you have an economy that's growing at
three percent a year and debt that's growing at
two percent a year, you're actually reducing the
significance of that debt relative to the size
of the economy. How frequently do you hear that
discussed in these conversations about debt and
deficit? And then, of course, lastly, we have to
remember that there is debt that is stimulative.
And I'm sorry you can increase the deficit. Now,
I'm talking about the deficit. You can increase
the deficit in a way that is economically
stimulative and you can increase the deficit in a
way that's not. So, for example, when you consider
the multiplier effect of food stamps versus
rich people putting money in a savings account,
the stimulative impact of food stamps which
gets spent, they get spent at local businesses,
supermarkets, which increases employment. Ba ba
ba ba ba. That the economic multiplier there is
dramatically higher than just a tax cut for the
rich, who mostly save that money because they
don't need that money to fund their lifestyle.
That's another aspect of debt and deficit. One
dollar of deficit is not always the same thing.
The question is, what are we getting? What are we
financing? Are we financing the richest people,
just saving a little more money that they don't
spend? Or are we financing some social program
with a very high multiplier effect? So anyway,
we can't really expect them to have that
conversation. They don't care to because
this debt deficit thing is just a political
football. And for many Democrats, it is as well.
Just on the opposite side, August 16th is the 16th
anniversary of The David Pakman Show. It flew by,
it flew by, and we are doing a one day membership
special, I would love for you to take advantage
of it. If you would like to be notified about this
incredible membership special on August 16th, get
a membership. I'm sorry, get on my newsletter at
David Pakman Dotcom. And on the 16th you'll get an
email telling you how to sign up for it. Remember
that The David Pakman Show doesn't have a money
tree, I've got eggplants, I've got tomatoes, but
no money tree in the backyard. We do depend on the
support of viewers and listeners like you through
the membership program. To support the show you
can sign up at join Pakman
Dotcom. It would be my pleasure
to welcome you into the ranks of membership.